[Music]
former president trump's lies about the
2020 election are dividing the
republican party and the most recent
rejection of the former president's
claims is coming from his former vice
president mike pence
president trump said i had the right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong and frankly
there is no idea more on american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president
however many other republicans are
embracing and even promoting the former
president's falsehoods and in florida
the gop wants to create a special police
force for election fraud which is
raising alarms among voting rights
activists ed o'keefe has more
well why should you make voting harder
cecile schoon runs florida's nonpartisan
league of women voters and is concerned
a proposal to establish a new police
unit to investigate elections fraud is
designed to keep minorities from voting
bringing law enforcement and having them
be around looking for problems there is
a concern and there is a fear and there
is that chilling factor that they are
going to target
black people republican governor ron
desantis first introduced the idea last
year this will facilitate the faithful
faithful enforcement of election laws
and will provide floridians with the
confidence that their vote will matter
the current proposal stands at 25
investigators and officers across
multiple departments desantis and
florida republicans are also pushing for
new legislation that among other things
adds even more id requirements to
absentee ballots florida's republican
secretary of state laurel lee oversees
elections we're very confident that we
hit a great intersection between making
voting accessible and keeping voting
secure well if it's so easy convenient
and safe
why do you need to make all these
changes every election brings
opportunities to look at what went well
and what could be better alleged voter
fraud has been rare in florida since the
2020 elections out of over 11 million
votes cast only four people have been
arrested for trying to vote twice but
lee says she supports the new election
police unit because we simply don't have
the resources right now to be the
partners we want to be to state and
local law enforcement these resources
would allow us to do even more to
support our partnerships with those
groups and be prepared for any
challenges to come democrats in the
state legislature are strongly opposed i
think we should be afraid of a political
election police goon squad the new
proposals come just nine months after
desantis signed another law with voting
restrictions like limiting the use of
ballot drop boxes that's now being
challenged in federal court it was
really an unneeded law leon county
election supervisor mark earley is set
to testify this week he's scrambling to
keep up with all the changes they can
make the law but we need to make sure
the law works and so that's really
become a huge part of my job now
early is worried all the changes will
confuse voters and scare off employees
and volunteers he needs to run elections
i think it becomes controversial
adversarial it takes some of that
special feeling that you're really
part of a trusted cadre of folks working
to make democracy work
so republicans in at least two other
states are pushing similar ideas and
georgia gop gubernatorial candidate
david perdue is vying to establish his
own election police force and in arizona
a republican state senators pushing for
a bureau of elections that would have
subpoena power tony
so ed as you point out there are
vanishingly few cases of actual election
fraud and zero evidence of any kind of
systematic fraud and ron desantis
himself said that florida had a gold
standard election in 2020 so what's
behind this new effort in florida and by
all these republicans in different
states
politics it's about appealing to the
trump base look at our most recent cbs
news poll just last month found eight in
ten republicans believe at least some
people vote or cast ballots illegally
and two-thirds of republicans think
voter fraud was widespread in the 2020
election despite no evidence of that or
any court case backing it up so even
though former president trump won
florida in 2020 president biden flipped
arizona and georgia those two other
states considering this republicans are
trying to do what they can to keep those
states in their calling tony all right
it remains to be seen how it will affect
the actual vote in 2022 and 2024 ed
thank you very much